[Music]  well the golden knights are hermetically  sealed fighting against the virus spread  the silver knights  are trying their best not to be in a  pandemic predicament of their own  today's exhibition game versus san jose  was  canceled after the second period out of  caution it is important to note that  there was not  a positive test in the henderson locker  room but it appears the san jose side  worries they had a concerning result and  in the middle of today's preseason game  the ahl removed the players from the ice  to mitigate  any further spread the silver night's  regular season debut  is still set for next saturday